please do not return to real give us all
your permission to do so by the council
staff
please note this meeting will be audio
recorded
please switch off mobile phones or turn
them to silence
members there are four microphones on
tables for your use
during the meeting when i invite you to
speak please wait until there is a
microphone in front of you
before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing loop
of the ordeal recording where possible
please help by passing microphones to
each other and use the handheld and
antibacterial lights on the tables
if you do touch the microphones
[Music]
[Music]
members
[Music]
thank you
members apologies for absence
we have received no apologies for
absence
[Music]
this is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
by the bookshop being the essex county
council
member ferocious south
are there any declarations of investment
i'm sorry
[Music]
are there any declarations of interest
[Music]
can you wait a moment please
um
is
thank you very much
[Music]
thank you
um
[Music]
thank you very much for watching
uh
[Music]
thanks for stopping
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
my husband is still listening to the
director of rockford support was limited
despite the signing some months ago in
the interest of transparency
i also declare that i can see the
communications from both projects
with lobbyists and brawler homes and
also rvc
on this application remain open minded
but to avoid any risk of apparent
influence
with
that's all this is good
[Music]
[Music]
okay
and foreign
[Music]
[Music]
can i ask all members if ever the
additional addendums please
uh to answer any questions that members
may have on the legal advice
that is included into the meeting report
at appendix 3
pages 6132-6134
members the officers officer will
present a full
report this evening which will cover all
the information presented
to the committee on the 26th of november
however we need to be focused on the
specific
reasons why that professionals further
november
our needs are addressed in
paragraphs 2.1 for 2.45
on pages 6.2 to 6 11
on the report before us this evening and
ask quincy to
present please
[Music]
the northern boundary just jumps past
the eastern end of oxford road to the
north and runs along the
rail gardens the properties that's going
to oxford road
it then turns south and it runs also
along the regardless of properties
and some of these some properties on
ashford road
the application then has a southern
boundary with properties on the watchful
garden way
firstly protest road in the drive to the
southeastern corner
the eastern boundary and juts out in
this position here's this triangle here
and then runs up this pipe here the site
also includes um
small additional areas connecting
through to ashley road one here
one here and a larger area here
which includes these two properties and
then a section
of attendance this is also
a section of the application site
between two existing properties
in this area here
[Music]
on um road and straight ahead in the
middle of the screen you'll see
some of the properties in the
northeastern corner of the site between
the north western corner of the site and
this is
one of the commercials
so this on screen now is an extract of
the council's allocation plan
and in particular the the policy seo
eight site annotation
the landscape is turtle informing the
majority of the application site
and is specifically identified by the
council foreign
a small area of the application site to
the east so this this triangle i pointed
out earlier
and then a section just coming up to the
edge the eastern end of oxford road
lies outside the site allocation and
this remains designated wing belt
in this part of the site strategic open
green space is proposed which would be a
useful lander for it
in the green land
so on screen now is the proposed phasing
plan
this application seeks out one plan
commission for a total of 662 runnings
and a community building with all
matters of scale landscaping
layout access and appearance to be
determined
in relation to phase one the phase one
is
the sort of reddish coloured area to
exclude
the area of land here which is from the
community building
um but phase one includes all of the
area to the eastern
boundary which would be the strategic
open space
and also the existing ditch
running east to west across the site
there's also some
more two more parcels of open space here
that's also within phase one
phase one um in relation to places two
and three outline planning commission is
sought only
that only the matters of layout and
access are for consideration
at this stage so faces two and three are
the blue areas
and the green areas on that final screen
so this final screen is the phase one
layout plan
within a phase one a mix of detached
semi-detached
terraced and flooded housing is proposed
the entrance avenue
which is here would lead off the main
vehicle access
and will be tree lined welling sprouting
the street leading to an emergency green
space here
with dwellings fronting around and onto
this street trees will also feature to
one of the roads leading northward here
all the proposed lines will be provided
with policy compliant community space
and on-site parking provision
a variety of parking solutions is
proposed including driveway parking to
the side
of lines and in front of dwellings as
well as parking ports to flatter blocks
parking to the front of the planet will
be broken up by tree planting
so that's in into this area here
the majority of one is decided on plots
with direct boundaries will be sighted
such as the rear elevation would face
the site boundary an appropriate
separation will be achieved
so that that's these areas here
to ensure that impacts relating to
overlooking and overshadowing would not
cause unreasonable harm to the amenity
of existing residents
i'll take you then to
the layout which includes their phases
two and three
the lady out of the phase of two and
three again proposes a mix of dwelling
types detached to our landscape
which in the main was shrunk onto the
proposed green spaces
including the east west ditch so that's
this area here
so you've got a series of dwellings
which front onto this space
from facing south here and then the
glowing's facing
north on the side of the ditch
this is also the case for the eastern
parkland so here the layout will see
playing space in the eastern parkland
here and here there'll be two vehicle
crossings over the ditch
um i might be able to just leave
[Music]
indicated by the yellow arrows so
there's one pedestrian point here
towards the east
and one here this is a vehicle crossover
of the
ditch another pedestrian crossing point
here a vehicular frosting point here and
another pedestrian link across there
this would allow for good connectivity
for pedestrians within the development
allotments are proposed within the
eastern boundary within the eastern
parkland
and there in this northeastern corner
but off the site here
the children's play space and the mx
track for just sitting out on that
planet
so the children's takes place in the dnx
track is also placed in the eastern part
and this position here the pedestrian
cycling link would run length of the
eastern open space
from the drive to the south all the way
through to oxford road to the north
occupants of the site as well as
existing residents would benefit from
good pedestrian links to allow access on
foot
so a number of nearby facilities and
amenities including local primary
schools
in addition to the whole farm infant and
junior schools opposite the site of
national road
waterman primary school is just off plan
here
just to the southeast of the site
further off plan
but it's important in walking distance
from the site
and now take members to some of the
street scenes that have been provided
the scale and appearance of dwellings
composed within phase one
is also for determination in this
application
the plan or screen shows a selection of
street scenes proposed within phase one
the street scene at the top of the
screen
here is a section of the entrance avenue
which would be
often proposed vehicular access to the
societal washington road
these proposed plans have a mix of 2 and
2.5 story
the traditional form incorporating
pitchfoods and positioning of windows
and doors
which will exhibit a strong degree of
symmetry a mix of render and brickwork
facial materials are proposed
the streets seen second from bottom so
this one here
includes the proposed larger three-story
flattened block with use of contrasting
facing materials to break up the
elevations
the scheme will deliver the council's
policy requirement that thirty five
percent of the drive to be affordable
in terms of appearance the market and
affordable properties proposed within
facebook will be similar with the same
palette-facing materials to be used
the street scene seconds from top
[Music]
so i'll just zoom out so you can see
them both together so the bottom street
scene
is a series of largely affordable
properties
and in spain and appearance these
properties would be similar
to take members too one of the
illustrative street scene visuals
contained within a submitted design code
this is an image looking towards the
entrance avenue
which would lift ashing the road from
within the larger green
amenity space proposed within phase one
housing houses in front of this green
space and be a 2.5 storyline to create a
different character
and send some place to this part of the
site in terms of scale layout
access appearance and landscaping it is
considered that the proposed scheme
would achieve good design in keeping
with the characters for locality
as well as these detailed matters other
key matters after consideration and the
determination of this application
are set out in the committee report but
take you back to the proposed two and
three
slightly layout plan
which shows the whole of the site
including strategic open green spaces
in the southeastern corner members will
note
two attenuation plans are proposed
surface water from the development
parcels will flow into these
ponds via a pipe to network be stored
and then discharge offsite
to controlled rate in addition the flood
alleviation scheme is proposed as part
of this application
to address an existing surface water
flood risk to parts of the site the key
features of the proposed flood
remediation scheme
include a proposed attenuation basis
adjacent to part of the northern
boundary
that's in this area here
and a ditch along the western boundary
of this so the ditch would run along
here
which would outfall to the existing
ditch which biceps society runs
east-west
so along here
water from the eastern end of the ditch
was then finally out fought
to the attenuation areas in this area
for site
these features will ensure that none of
the proposed weather will be subject to
unacceptable risk for surface water
flooding the proposal of the mediation
scheme would also reduce surface waters
to some existing nearby drawings
particularly to fly its downstream to
the south
and take members back to the proposed
phase one layout
which improves the proposed new vehicle
access onto ashland road
the formation of this access will
involve changes within the highway
this is in this area here
[Music]
including the formation of ghost flight
hand turn and the wide end of the
northbound carriageway on washington
road
which would reduce the width of a
section of the footwear to the west
these works would also necessitate the
removal of an oak tree
within the footprint the loss of the oak
tree would be compensated for in part at
least by a financial contribution
to enable significant tree planting
within the district and propose
additional
highway tree planting within washington
road just
just to the north yeah
looking south at approximately the point
at which the new access to the site is
proposed
the pedestrian crossing which is shown
on screen will remain
be upgraded as required essex county
council highways
authority raised no objection to the
proposed vehicular access to the site on
the grounds of safety
the submitted transport assessment in
addendum to this as robustly assessed
the impact of traffic from the proposed
development on the local highway network
the commission report details the
mitigation proposed which will include
improvements to some of the options in
the locality
the report is also clear that some
residual impact on the local highway
network
but as his current council republicans
authorities do not consider that this
impact
will be severe in addition to junction
improvements that will be required of
the developer
significant financial contributions
towards public transport improvement
and cycle improvements would also be
provided
so i'm just going to take you back do
the phase two and three layouts
the financial and other contributions
will be provided to mitigate impact on
the increased population including
in relation to education provision where
contributions will be paid in relation
to early years in child care
primary and secondary education
the land set aside for a community
building which
is in this area here the southwestern
corner
would be initially offered to the nhs
for delivery of a new primary healthcare
facility on site
in addition to a significant financial
contribution towards this new
infrastructure provision
the site has been allocated by oxford
district council for residential
development
and the delivery of housing here will
support the requirements that the
council maintain a five-year housing
plan supply
the development would also deliver a
significant number of affordable homes
the development will create an
attractive well-designed place for new
residents in a sustainable location
within walking distance of a range of
existing
facilities the site is within
potential image
so the stars on the screen point out
some of the facilities in the locality
the site is within walking distance of
local facilities and amenities
including a number of schools so there's
the whole farm
infantry junior school another primary
school further south
and then another one and towards the
staff in eastern corner
there are some shop facilities on
ashford road to the north
and a secondary school within more
conditions of the site also
this application was presented to the
development committee last year then the
decision was taken to defer the item to
enable further information
to be provided by officers in relation
to a number of matters raised by members
of that committee
further information related to these
matters has been provided are set out on
the addendum committee report
the recommendation relates more than
approval subject to the recommended
planning conditions
and a section of six legal agreements to
the heads of terms
as detailed in the original committee
report and in addition to those changes
and additional requirements sent out in
addendums
and the addendum committee report thank
you
thank you
[Music]
five minutes
thank you
thank you thank you thank you for
quieting me for the opportunity to speak
again in support of our planning
application
nearly seven months ago the committee
voted to defer the decision on the
application
to take advice about six specific
suggested reasons for refusal
the identity report discloses in detail
the application is recommended for
approval
the previous comprehensive committee
debate has given your home a welcome
opportunity
to further scrutinize the proposals for
this the last of your major
allocated local plan sites
in the weeks following a critical debate
we put in training a full technical
overview
of the transport elements of the
application the review concludes
that the access and highways improvement
scheme has been designed
modeled independently assessed and
safely audited
to see that the safety of all boat users
is assured
there are four schools with only a short
walk at the development side
but the existing road signage provides
no advanced warnings
to alert drivers the proposals provide a
comprehensive package of salvage
road surfacing and markings to radically
improve
the wider highway safety environment
here in response to concerns raised
over a recorded accident since the last
committee
we are adding to the package of highway
measures to include
an extra financial contribution of 50
000 pounds
to deliver a new pedestrian hospital
raised lane
we have also proposed improvements to
the frontage of the hulk farm schools
and should we be writing and set this
evening we will continue dialogue to
support this
throughout the planning process it has
become clear that the development of
necessary highway improvements will lead
to the loss of the
this aspect of the works has been
reviewed but remains unavoidable
in response further additional treatment
is planned
and a direct compensation payment is
agreed
since your previous debate we have more
than doubled the financial
compensation for the loss of the tree by
proposing an additional
contribution of 75 000 pounds to be
spent on public tree planting projects
throughout the district
we were also interested to hear the
previous discussion relating to the
delivery of new youth facilities
and we've gone away and reflected on
this and are pleased to be including an
additional 75 000 pounds
for the support of further facilities in
discussions with officers
both of the district and parish council
we have also recommended that this be
reinvented
for the residents of the area to clarify
the debate around the density of
development
the more homes supposed to achieve a
density of 33.1 ohms
per hectare this is a low density scheme
being slightly higher than the minimum
density requirement of your local plan
the revised development for local fan
site
ser one which is approved by this
committee earlier this month
achieved a much higher density of
development the approved development of
722 million
str1 is now 44 greater
than the previously approved 500 phones
and significantly greater than the
actually devoted
to conclude we realize that new
development of homes will be
controversial wherever they go
we also recognize how sensitive this
site has been which is why we have made
every effort to deliver
support for local priorities there are
we are told
over one thousand people on the local
housing wages
this development with its 35 affordable
homes
will help give these individuals and
their families hope for a home of their
own
all too often this incredible
fundamental hidden need for a roof over
your head
is simply disregarded by those opposing
new homes
law homes is not a huge plc housing
and we we always take great care to
ensure that we deliver
as much of a contribution towards local
communities as we can
we always prefer that our developments
are approved at the local level
so these considerable benefits can be
delivered in agreement
with the community the range of benefits
has increased by two hundred thousand
pounds since the last committee
are now standing over eight point five
million pounds in total
covering nhs schools and a huge range of
other infrastructure
as we move into the next stages of this
project i thank you for putting your
faith in us
and respectfully ask that you endorse
the recommendation
and approve this planning application
thank you very much for listening
thank you very much
our next sorry
quite honorable sorry mom mark france
thank you you've got five
i wish the most strongly object to this
application for the following reasons
the site was originally designated for
500 properties the floor increased this
to around 665
a classic pace of over development
there's subsequent offer and will face a
strong local protest to reduce this
number by all of
three merely adds insult to injured
while the design itself reminds me of
the soviet army barracks in east germany
at the height of the cold war
however my principal objection is on
highways
as i believe that the proposed
development will have an unsafe and
unacceptable impact
on the local highway network the
applicant's own transport consultants
can
see that without remediation number of
key junctions along the ashland road and
nearby
will be overwhelming by 2029 by the
extra traffic
but their proposed remediations are
unsafe
for instance the applicants propose to
expand the approach to one of the many
roundabouts on the actual road
from one lane to two even though essex
county council as the highways authority
recently reduced it from two ladies
to one specifically on safety grounds
so that is a safety failure
straightforward
similarly narrowing the footpath
opposite the two schools facing the
proposed access to the development
itself a bad location is clearly unsafe
too
another safety failure i appreciate
ecc the local highways authority is not
formally objected to this application
but there are two points to make first
in my 20 years experience as the local
mp they rarely object to
any major applications of highways
grounds
and many involved in essex local
government know that and often complain
about it
secondly and in fairness to their
highways officers
they pointed out to me and others before
that under the nationally planning
policy framework
they can only object to proposals which
have a severe effect on traffic
that there is no clear definition of
what a severe effect
actually is similarly the rdc's planning
officer's report is fatally flawed
as it states in at least six places
that the traffic effect is not severe
but without once defining what a severe
effect
is so it's an assertion but which is
being presented
as a fact so what is a severe traffic
effect
para 109 of the national planned policy
framework really says this i quote
development should only be prevented or
refused on highways down as if there
would be an unacceptable impact on
highway safety or
the residual documented impacts on the
road net network would be
severe however that's not the definition
so i
recently asked parliament's professional
research service the house of comms
library
if they could find an official
definition and if there were any other
planning guidance or parliamentary
questions
that could clarify this is what they
came back to me with earlier this week
you're interested in whether the word as
severe as you find in planning
in relation to traffic for new
developments the short answer is the
word severe council section
of the mppf on transport but i
have been unable to identify a further
specific definition
the library then confirmed that severe
is not defined again
yet nor could they find other guys which
defined it either
the best they could find was a written
parliamentary question dated in 2014 but
which did specifically ask the
government
to define a severe and used context the
reply from the then minister of state
planning brandon lewis is instructive in
the point about severe
it says this it is for the local
planning authority
in considering planning applications or
the planning inspector and considering
planning appeals
to consider whether improvements can be
undertaken within the transport network
that cost effectively limit the impact
of the development contract
determining whether the limited
[Music]
authority to decide so in summary
chairman it all comes down to what
represents a severe effect on local
attraction
roger district council can't define it
essex county council highways
can't define it they've previously
admitted that's why they didn't
object it i have that on the records
because they couldn't define it
the house of commons library can't
define it and even the government can't
define it either
but that that pq gives you your answer
in the end
the local planning authority must define
it for themselves
so very clearly it's down to this
committee to decide if you decide
tonight
that this is unsafe which it is
and that it has a severe effect on
traffic
which it does but under the national
policy planning framework you're
absolutely within your rights
to turn down this application and as the
local leader appeared on behalf of my
constituents
that is exactly what i appealed to you
today
[Music]
there are five schools
right thank you madam chairman
notation um 17th using data now seven
years old from 2014 and 15
described four major intersections in
the rocha town centre area
which were highlighted as having traffic
safety and congestion issues
it specifically states that high levels
of congestion are observed with all
three approaches to the action of road
road west street roundabout it also
states
we observe medium to high levels of
congestion on the majority of acting
good road
all this before the whole road and brace
lane developments have been built
quoting from the report presented this
evening
page 6.5 section 218
[Music]
so no capacity improvement there
in this assessment use software and
algorithms to assess traffic impact
in two cases including the junction just
highlighted
the software predicted the junction flow
to the older theoretical capacity
with queuing and delay rising
exponentially
it also added that the development
traffic will have delay and theory in
the junction
i didn't dismiss these results saying
they should be treated with caution
so you've seen that it's the software
and algorithm don't support
the results you want dismiss them
using the phase one average of 2.2 car
spaces
this means potentially 1450 cars for the
development of 662 points
even with an average movement of one
return vehicle uh journey for a car day
this ramps up some additional 3 000
vehicle movements per day
entering orexin road or person cottage
road
bernie mundo said the argent assessment
page 71 paragraph 6.1 extending
discussing the increased level of
distress traffic congestion in the
network says
some drivers are likely to take an
alternative route if able to avoid
congestion
supported by satellite navigation with
long traffic
all potential alternative routes are
rightly described in the ringworx agency
report
as congestion hot spots especially
recreate which narrows from single lane
under the railway bridge with traffic
light control
in the two all discussions seem to be
focused on african-americans
let's not forget the secondary access
for the proposed uh
breeding-based development for more than
200 houses
400 plus vehicles is by the person
crosstalk
this road is environments on narrow
residential roads with sharp paints
tightness introduced from on-street
parking and little offspring alternative
it's also close to rival austin's
primary school
within the ardennes report is a 19-page
stage one
road safety audit carried out by m s
track ability
which identified a number of risk areas
for example on page seven of the report
it says at the junction of coding costas
road with roger garnermate
excessive flows or queuing at the
junction could lead to side impact
conditions of rear-end shunts
yet in the main body united's
all accesses have been subject to an
independent stage one road safety orbit
and that no significant concerns have
been raised as a result of this
how
[Music]
during the long 5th period five schools
and a nursery having different start and
finish time
but also at any time during the weekend
or any weekday
there's campus photographic evidence and
support this statement
indented by residents i starting to see
sdra policy stating that ecological
hybrid capacity
there is a minute it just makes a
personal statement
there have been some comments made about
in the past week challenging my
credibility in making various statements
for the record i've studied engineering
for four years as part of an engineering
cadetship
i hold an honest degree in business
studies called material planning
logistics management foreign parts of
europe
western europe and petersburg
deeply involved in material and vehicle
transportation finally i'm a fellow of
the royal society of the advancement
development manufacturing
more commonly known as fresno and
someone has to attack another person as
it seems to have been happening against
me
it's often the case they can't tackle
thank you
thank you very much
thank you madam chairman and members for
giving me the opportunity to speak
as both the leader and ward council for
the area in which this proposed
development says
i feel a compelling need to speak
[Music]
in november 2020 i made a speech at the
planning meeting which covered a broad
range of issues
the outcome of that meeting was to defer
a decision in order to take
time in which to focus upon and consider
six
key areas of concern i have not allowed
enough time this evening to comment on
all six so i will restrict my remarks to
just
two of what i consider are the most
important reasons
firstly to create a completely new main
entrance
of this development opposite the
influence and junior school
is in my opinion sheer luminous however
the highway experts
i would model the road layout however
the highway expert model group layout
and however pretty
the plan looks to reduce pavement width
to a minimum standard
and create an area where cars bicycles
adults and young children who with the
best will in the world
will do unpredictable things along a
very busy highway
is absolutely painless and is frankly a
recipe for disaster
this element of the proposal alone is
quite disturbing
as it will create a complex road layout
directly opposite oxfam school this will
become the main
access and ingress point for pedestrian
traffic
and will potentially lead to injuries
and potential fatalities
with young and other members of the
community the integration
of pedestrian conflict which is further
exacerbated at school time
cannot be overcome simply by mitigation
measures
and by our state chairman i take strong
objection to the photograph that was
shown
that portrays ashington road as a quiet
country lane
i would be finding myself both in my
moral duty
and my conscience gift heaven could be a
serious injury or for tunnetia first
at the new junction turning
now to the other of the two reasons
highway
matters and traffic volumes along
ashland road
everyone who lives and works in the area
knows what a significant artery of the
remote network
it is on a daily basis at potentially
all times of the day
it can become heavily congested
congested
and it constantly lays important users
in order
[Music]
alternative access from the development
the rochefort garden wave state is a
well-designed and attractive development
but with relatively narrow roads
combined with on street park
navigating via sunset avenue or the
drive
all converging factually on up to
washington road
which is the very root of the problem
once i acknowledge this site was adopted
back in 2014 within the local plan
it was i believe a huge oversight not to
require
to make sure to make a such significant
residential development conditional
on being served by a completely new
relief growth
which does not impact or exacerbate
congestion along hashing the road
it is acknowledged that washington is
one of the busiest of its type in this
part of essex
and the approved industry market level
is set at severe
i believe we have been let down very
randomly by essex county council the
statutory authority for highways
which is not more robustly resisting
approval of the grounds of
increased traffic volumes how long do we
have to go on
for before someone stands up and has the
word
severe tested in more absolute terms
rather than the airy fairy cop-out
approach
which is currently taken and i would
like to compliment
the right honourable mark francois mp
for making just that point
with the likelihood that on average each
property will have at least two cars it
is obvious to anyone
that usage will contribute significantly
to an already
heavily congested road network
acknowledged by essex county council
highways experts
even before any further development
takes place
to the owner capacity and i have already
reached a severe level
by adding thousands more yes thousands
of additional movements per day
i know the proposal talks about several
changes to the road layout to long after
the road
none of these actually address capacity
it is interesting to note that the
ashland
road recreate junction will be changed
back to a layout similar to that
which existed previously and which was
changed on county highways
recommendations
a couple of years ago on so-called
grounds of safety
that defies logic to me and suggests to
me safety is low
on the list of importance in this matter
you've approved
this application would therefore have a
serious and detrimental effect on
pedestrian safety
and lead to an unacceptable level of
risk in
conclusion about the chairman the
proposed development is totally
inappropriate in standard location
as well over burdening the existing
infrastructure
in the area chairman i accept this is a
difficult decision for the development
committee tonight
but i should like to thank you and
members for listening to my concerns
thank you
[Applause]
that's one point members if you're any
of you are hot and the gentleman in
particular
please do something
thank you
it's american that's great if you don't
it's tough it goes to appeal
no counsellor or officer should ever
feel that they're being breathed
as deputy leader of this council i am
called to such behavior
and perhaps laws should take us back to
their board yeah
[Applause]
thank you and a lot of what i was going
to say has already been said and i won't
quit
his time going over it again i learned
to simply say
that i am absolutely appalled at the
message highways
and being the county council i am
reported the way that they have
treated this particular application
despite many meetings that i have had
with them
with regards to the design
the layout and the principle of the
junction that they're talking about
percy cottage road is not suitable as a
second entrance
it needs to be vastly widened to be able
to deal with that
particular issue and it doesn't stop
there lots of garbage away
and somerset revenue and all of around
there
companies are actually putting their
sums of money in for various junction
improvements like cambodia
and various other junctions we've had
this before there is very little
that can be done with those junctions to
make them improve
the hall road west street hashington
road junction
the only thing you could do there would
be to demolish a school
fill in the river and move around the
bridge to be able to actually do any
improvements
so what can you what can you do there is
nothing you can do
i'll pick up on a previous point a point
on the previous speaker
the only solution to the road network
would be watching
which being honest it ain't really needs
to come back she'd recognize
it is medieval road layout the only
solution
would be to put in a new road and
the only place that i could see that
that would go would be from showing
waterway up to
retro road and you'd have to include the
railway bridge
so there's that i don't know if the
company has really looked
at these particularly german i'd like to
pick up on one or two bits and pieces
within the addendum itself
it is very unclear with the comments of
the officers
with regards to the federal crossing
up in brazil they suggest that he
shouldn't be part of the heads of terms
yet money for the development
repairs or improvements to the aberdeen
junction
have been included there is a desperate
need for the zebra crossing or similar
and in that goes we've had meetings with
the school there has been instances
there
i cannot see any reason why that should
not
be included if the cut if the committee
is doing
this i still do not understand why a
tree that some
two to three hundred years would need to
be removed the design
and the sufficient room on that road on
the other side of the road to be able to
actually
design around that yet they offer
some money to actually to compensate for
that
it's unclear where that money will go
there's a trees
but who's going to have control of that
where is it going to go it is very
unclear within the
start
there are various projects along the
ashland road that i know the local
highways penalties looking at yet there
is no
does not appear to be any assistance
coming forward for that
particular particular scene improvements
to
zebra crossings etc
i hope the committee will actually
confirm some of these points if they are
reminded to actually agree this this
this
application but i cannot see without
some dramatic work i need a new road
that anything can be done to relieve the
problem
along the ashland road thank you
chairman of that
i'm not happy about this application
despite
scia showed an application of 500 in our
current local plane
which has been adopted by retro district
council
i did not vote for the local plan
although it said it was passed by the
administration
and that this site is de facto approved
for residential housing of around 500
properties
the application is for 6.62
the access creates the loss of the
massive
admired local trade and i believe the
tpo
is in place whilst he stated that other
accidents were considered
and that this was deemed most acceptable
to whom money will not replace
the 200 year old trade
the previous speakers have i think
adequately covered
the many traffic issues that this
application
brings about however this is a hybrid
application aside from the concerns over
the additional
162 that's 32
more than originally visited the
application gives the details of 223
hosts which are also up
for detailed approval although we need
the right type of housing i believe that
the type of estate being provided with
the local area which is adjacent
in the officers report he states that
nearby properties
are mainly semi-detached and selling
mainly sorry semi-detached bungalows and
shallow bundles
or detached and semi-detached houses
yet this design incorporates potentially
2.5 storage houses and three starring
flats
not really in keeping with the local
area
the claim that the three-story plants in
san diego close
are nearby as misleading stanley curse
is set
well back behind the other side
washington road
to the application site and it's not
visible to the site
or the approach in my view we are
sacrificing a
precious green bed and open spaces we
should be getting something
that we are all very proud of
also rdc has policies admittedly often
ignored
that social housing also known as
affordable housing
should be pepper potty and tenure blind
in this design it is not the social
housing is clustered
and certainly not 10-year blind private
housing is accommodated with garages
social housing just an allocated parking
space
in my experience this can lead to future
problems and also does not help build a
community spirit amongst the new
residents
for the reason stated above i do not
think this application should be
approved for however
should the committee decide otherwise i
would like a condition
that the applicants carefully consider
the maintenance of any privately owned
and maintained public space in
conjunction
with the water councillors and the
portfolio holder
to reach an agreement that prevents
potential future problems
for residents and council alike and that
is
very important in the light of
experience that we have at the moment
in our district whilst i appreciate
that this is a difficult decision
committee members
i strongly trust that this application
will be refused
for the many reasons stated of ourselves
and previous speakers
[Music]
thank you very much
speaking this evening uh as a one of the
hawker westward
members and i would like to speak on the
wider issues
which will be slightly different to what
my colleagues have already referred
to not only as an adjacent world
councillor
to the proposed development but i am
also a resident living
in victory road therefore i have
first-hand experience
and i share my concerns as do residents
that this development will have a
further
negative impact on the sheer volume
of traffic which will have a severe
effect on our daily lives
it is already a heavily congested road
during rush hour on a daily basis
the bottleneck of traffic can tell back
as far as ashington rose to the railway
bridge
where a single lane of traffic is
controlled by traffic lights
due to the narrow underpass at the
railway bridge
if as suggested rectory road is to be
one of the escape routes
then i am sure it will be further
gridlocked
by the additional volume of traffic
which
this development of 662 houses
will cause if it is endorsed
[Music]
um
thank you
advice
thank you
all right
one question
please uh that's right
jenny just got a quick question on
during the weight loss
[Music]
i'm sure
thank you chairman um we go into one
point um which relates to the
narrative on item 2.34
86.9 ecc
tesos county council says we also advise
that we do not consider
proposals to reduce the foot and cycle
and start school
to be unacceptable provided it meets a
minimal technical standard
for a shared or segregated area however
as an outline in our initial corporate
response
it will be significant downgrade from
what is already in place and is
therefore
undesirable from an education and public
health perspective
the width of the paving was put there
for a reason
what has changed nothing if anything
there are more reasons
why it should be retained the junction
is facing the school
vehicles access to the site can't
believe that's eventually applied by his
lane
which can only be accessed by assad
ashland road
therefore it means that every
construction traffic will be passing the
school
on a regular basis not only for weeks
but from not only for months but for
years
say the attention of the payment win in
front of the school
in excess of the minimum three weeks of
wide required by ecc
they have not said how many how much
will
this claim would be 10 millimeters
is in excess of three meters the safety
of pedestrians
is is paramount and i cannot support
this
if they are going to reduce this
painfully thank you thank you
thanks for standing
thank you of all
i've got to say that this planning
proposal scr 8 was done in 2014
and in 2014 obviously traffic was a lot
different than what it is now
and we couldn't obviously foresee
what it actually wins through the
ashland road
and as speaker has already said
the movements of 3000 movements
will cause quite a lot of congestion
i just ask the officer
first of all in
we obviously learned that there was
going to be a development here
and had any considerations been
thought about since 2014
or is it just at this moment in time
that we're at because i feel that this
is all of us
you know sort of a quick job so we've
gotta get this done
so that's my first question my second
question is
um due to the fact that
rdc has allocated more homes
to a previous site i would like to ask
the officer if the condition could be
put on the site that
no extra homes will be put
on the site as it is already
uh over developed by considering
and thirdly
due to the fact that there is really
only one
main entrance to the site
is it i don't know if this is a planning
policy or whether we can do it or
whatever i can say this but
i'm looking for other means of getting
onto the site as the main entrance to
the site
rather than where it is at the moment in
other words
is there a plausible entry to the site
other than what's already there
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
will be answered
[Music]
the last meeting the decision was
verbal and the reason was to explore
further information i
actually voted for the deferral because
i felt that we were lacking
in some of the information that we
needed to
use to be able to make a qualified
decision
on this i
then set about asking questions and i
will explain those questions
so as the committee understands where i
was coming from
there is a reason for that number one
when we had our last meeting
essex highway representative was asked
because of the result of the
recommendation on the traffic assessment
for a improvement to be done to the
cambodian member
um when asked what that improvement
would be
the answer was it's complicated
so i set about then to ask for
explanation
what those uh that would be
the the problem is that most of the
improvements that are recommended here
are for a two lane
approach to a roundabout to be
introduced the annual in roundabout
already has
a two-lane approach so it's not
unreasonable
for me to ask what those proposals are
i have been asking for that after an
answer to that
since february i have written a number
of emails
and i have not been furnished with a
reply
the traffic assessments
rely on improvements to the
roundabouts going by the two-lane
approach
when we had the whole road development
that is exactly what they did there
so i wanted to be sure in my own mind
that that solution actually works
so i asked for a copy of the traffic
assessment of the whole road
and i asked for traffic surveys either
side
of the development that would then give
me
an answer as to whether that solution
actually works
i don't think that's an unreasonable
thing to ask
i got a copy of the traffic assistance
and i've got a copy of
the traffic survey with 2010
having asked 19 times over for a
traffic survey which was after
the uh the the development be done
um i was messing with you
and i had it in writing that i was told
that i should actually go and find it
for myself
i find that dereliction of duty
in closing i support all the
uh traffic comments and comments have
been made on
traffic but i heard a um
a report on radio 4 not that on ago
and it was about the traffic survey that
has been done in the uk
in recent times now we are not
back fully yet to be open
from the advent of kobe but at this
moment in time
traffic is reported
to have increased 14
from pre-con coding times
now they could not have taken that into
consideration on the traffic
system we are already told that that
traffic assessment
is is uh that traffic assessment
points out to problems that we are going
to have without overcrowding on the runs
the 14 increase in in pre-coding traffic
is logical while we've been encoded
people are not used to having injuries
so there are much more delivery vehicles
on the
on the road in conclusion
i am absolutely appalled at the
disrespect that has been
shown as a sitting member of this
committee asking for legitimate
information to be able to be sure
of making the right decision and that
information being refused
if you have an issue like that after
this meeting would you like to send me
after the officers
that i already have and i got only
the members would have seen the email
and circulated by the legal
officer this afternoon basically telling
me
that i can't ask those questions what
yes you can have further discussion
after this
particularly before this committee
started discussing the item and
some very good arguments very strong
arguments
have been put forward there's been a
valid discussion
on local issues many opinions have been
expressed
i fully appreciate the motivation behind
points to be taken
i can recognize the passion of the
emotions
that's been expressing quite clearly
the majority of officers here this
evening do not want this development
to take place we're in the
i don't think perhaps fortunate position
this time
of having had a preferred item and there
has been time for
further advice to be solved by the
council specifically at the committee's
request
from the south looking at the
application
i've noted that quite clearly we've got
six or two houses here rather than the
500
but within the report there's no real
evidence of standards
to do with that increase in quantum not
being
met i've noted that since the
firmament we've obviously got an
increased contribution towards
community facilities i must admit in
looking at the plans again during the
presentation
i'm somewhat disappointed with the style
and the character of the proposals
in in phase one and i think that
if they if phase one of this application
tonight is perhaps
perhaps something thought could go into
subsequent
phases where we could perhaps avoid the
repetition and alignment of the proposed
but that's
my opinion but
as a committee we need to face the
elephant in the room
and that's that we have an officer
recommendation
for approval for this item
that approval recommended
and now further backed up by
independent formal legal advice
is based on planning guidance
and the form of advice that is
up and down the country the
the recommendation that he presented to
us
is a considered official position of
officers
it's based on professional advice
and it's objective it's
a technical examination
and as i mentioned we have had formal
legal advice
i'm afraid i whether you like or not i
do
have i do accept the highways
authorities position they are the former
authority that we would turn to
for advice lack of opinions and
they are saying that to a degree they
are content with what's
presented in front of us tonight
[Music]
i've stacked on the planning committee
for
more years and i care to remember and
i've got a good feel of
what can and what can't be taken into
account
i'm also very aware that i'm not a ward
member
i'm a district council member and i feel
duty bound to take the wider
impact of the application
on the district into account
i do have to reflect on the wider
population and its growth
i have to think about promoting
more sustainable ways of living rather
than just
accepting that the growth in in cars is
going to continue and i have to reflect
on the
work that has been done in the core
strategy
which is valid and this has got to be
part of our decision-making process
so i'm i'm not going to accept or say
that my hat i feel my hands
are tied behind my back and i've got to
simply accept what the officers say
to us i i believe
that given the terms and conditions
of which we must make our decisions and
the planning of authority
mean that i'm not
seeing a formal way
in which i can turn down
this application i don't want to say the
word reluctantly
going to accept the operator's
recommendation because
i've looked at the report i've taken the
evidences in front of us from the
various authorities
and based on the core strategy that we
have
i believe our
thank you
thank you this has been the most
difficult
application i've made a decision on all
the time
i've debated with myself for days over
there seeing both sides of it
we need housing and this is on our
development plan
but we also need to protect our
residents
both for their health and safety we have
five schools
a nursery um retirement homes down this
road
and the air pollution that will be
produced by the traffic down here i feel
that will damage their their health
their safety
and their well-being we've discussed
sevilla i've been trying to look for a
definition of severe
the nearest i can get is a definition of
severe
traffic problems is characterized by a
stellar space
and long queues of traffic on a daily
commute
is classed as severe now we head back
down atlanta road
not just in russia not just in school
drop off and pick up times
when we have delivery drivers you know
the local
supermarket delivering whatever
building works going on people having
new driveways
and not forgetting the game day
that does slow that road down which i
believe makes it severe and if we are
to find a definition of severe i think
that comes close to it
so there's been an increase in traffic i
understand
of 2.9 a year since 2014
now that wouldn't make uh 21
and it would be more than that i would
think and we had 16.4
more increasing the use of huddle cycles
i just think this is going to be
dangerous for our residents
and my conscience
and i heard someone else talk about
having a conscience before tonight
but my conscience i have to look after
the residents
[Music]
i'm still concerned about pedestrian
safety i've been out and i've actually
measured the road
the pavement i did with another castle
and it cuts a lot away and it also
cuts the cycle fast away i understand
from the map which you couldn't see
that well behind us but it goes up
one side the cycle path will still be
going up one side
cuts across the crossing then we are
expected
to get the cyclists who can't dismount
or think about 200 yards and then get
back on the bike
that's when the children are all coming
out of school this is an excellent
waiting to happen
i had a meeting um with various people
as monsters
and as people have always said we've
covered
we've had our parents are frightened
to take that their children go into this
public transport
so we've got an increase in cars so
i am very very concerned on the
pedestrian side
on this one thank you so much
wholeheartedly understand the views and
concerns of the residents
i also unders i also understand the
heart division that the officers have
had to make
yesterday the
500 adoption which has now changed
understandably i also understand that
concerns more
houses more cars but i still don't
believe that we've really really looked
into the infrastructure
not just the infrastructure schools
afford to capacity
doctors capacity
and i'm also quite concerned that um
hearing from counsellor mr drove about
your home
saying that they want to take this
committee to account
if it's not
passed tonight
as um as a counsellor i also
live on the main road the other side of
actually don't need to call cochley
and i do know i've sat in trump for over
an hour just to do a five-minute ride
as a committee we have to take into
account
all of the information all of the
concerns of councillors all the concerns
of residents
and so chairman as i've said
we are down if we do
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh reading all the fake work which
you've done over the last month
last couple weeks and the opinion we've
got from
um harrison
it seems that it's is
especially about the topic and
congestion and then i come back from
johnson this evening
i made a mistake of going through
and it took me 14 minutes to do two
miles
sorry i don't know if that is what this
congestion is like
um i really i really don't know
um looking at the advice you drop
from the uh barrister it's
if we don't support this it's likely to
go through a field
and on this advice we like to lose so
i can take that if you just cost us the
money but we'd end up getting the houses
[Music]
is
and this is my first planning meeting so
i feel like
[Music]
position following their advice which
they
obviously is the consultant they have to
do
i feel that their advice
[Music]
have made blah assumption that being the
homes being near
five schools that parents will walk
their children to school
this will not happen most mothers i
don't mean that any sort of gender
biased
mothers that are working mothers that
tend to be dropping the children off the
school in the car and rushing on
so the number of trips to schools
density of cars on the road is going to
increase exponentially um
regarding all roads one of the 106
movements was a new school
we're still waiting for that school
we're still waiting for a sixth county
council education department to provide
extra provisions whilst the money is
there sitting in
rdc's account waiting to use parents are
traveling
from rochester or road to hockley
and more congestion
which is an aggravating problem
the reports are great suggest that all
the roads in
and out of washington are already
severely congested
the single um lights at victory road
under the bridge
and my own experience of traveling ash
road when the school was emptied out is
convenience
it's almost oh god i
the officers i think have done excellent
work but i think the guidance
is letting down our residents
highways
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
and i think it's fair to say that this
is probably the most difficult
both academically
and emotionally i had to consider
i've also taken on board
and considered the various
representations made by residents
of the end of the public and of course
by our
local mp
as however
as a result of visitor i look at
perhaps these issues rather differently
from
the average man in the street and i know
mr
dad runs down by me there uh
there was a saying in my office
i'm a solicitor i don't deal emotion
and that's because we cannot allow
emotion to interfere
with a rational and proper judgment
if we refuse
this application
and the developer
appeals there's no guarantee
that if he succeeds which i
must assume that he would
there's no guarantee that we would have
the contributions quite up for quite
confusing
towards infrastructure and
other parts
it's quite possible
that the development would drive the
costs
and we could therefore by refusing this
application
we could end up in a situation far worse
than if we improved within
all the additional expense
and i'm struggling i have to say because
i'm still a human being
i understand
what other members and other speakers
have said
against the application
and many of which i share
but in making a decision
we are very much in the same
we need to apply
consideration as as a quasi-judicial
decision we cannot escape
and i i never fear that i will be in the
same position
as councillor smith
however in conclusion
may i express the hope given that
the government is now talking about
planning issues
and changing them may i express the hope
that our mp
with his contacts will
implore the government
to include in their deliberations
[Laughter]
thank you jim i'm sorry for being there
someone's long-winded
but there's a lawyer you will understand
of course i wouldn't expect anything
else
now for something like 45 years in
ashland talk through those years
i use this road safely
taking my way to work usually and i know
it can be very difficult at certain
times
other times today there's not very much
traffic on it
other than big times i've had many
sleepless nights night
regarding this application
interestingly today i had a meeting
along with other counsellors
with the head of case school
and some of the figures that came out
quite interesting
we have something like 600 pupils going
to his school from south end
most of those are not used in public
transport something like two-thirds
are coming by like by car
with their parents bringing them and i
guess this is something like 800 to a
thousand car movements a day
i really i i i appreciate how
people feel like in the residence i also
has a counsellor hear from people that
are desperate
i i really i am really struggling with
this decision
at the moment i really can't dismiss
this as an application
i would support it at the moment with
everything
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
i just want to clarify something about
the additional 50 000 pound
contribution that's been offered in
relation to a new pedestrian crossing a
brazen
lane and so just so that members are
clear
that as set out from the addendum
officers don't recommend that
this be part of the 106 as it turns
um that's not to say the crossing in
this particular location
may not be needed it may well be um
but the test for applying obligation
to members to consider something as a
planning obligation in relation to an
application
must meet certain legal tests and we
don't consider that this
particular financial contribution would
meet the
necessity test so in terms of it
the need for this process will not arise
specifically from the development
so we did put this question to us county
council hybris authority
and that is their view as well so what i
would say that if members were minding
to approve the application um that
contribution
does not form part of the proposal
the application at the moment in terms
of the recommendation so it would be for
a member to propose that that be added
um um
but that's to factor in um one of the
second
questions i think was about construction
access so that wood
is proposed to come from the north east
off grace lane
um and there's a condition 52 um
that requires details around
construction and access
[Music]
to the north this is oxford road um so
great lane is again off
uh to the east and it would come off an
existing farm access but i don't have
the extent of that to show on a plan
thank you
um
so
so yeah
so this is the additional area of
parking that's composed within the site
that would be not specifically set aside
for the school but it would be available
for use
for parents or others dropping
children off keeping children up so it's
this area here these spaces
over here
i had another question about um
i think it was too uh highway impact
since the 2014 allocation of this site
um and not to my knowledge in terms of
watchful council undertaking any
transport assessment following the site
being allocated into
that in the 2014 site allocation plan
it is at the point at which an
application then comes forward
in relation to that site allocation that
the developer is required to carry out
the
transport assessments to consider those
impacts
the next question was about would a
condition be appropriate
to if obviously these members were
minded to approve
to mean that no other housing could come
forward at the site
um i think my advice would be i don't
think that condition would be necessary
because on this site any
proposal for any additional housing
um above that shown on the plan to be
considered tonight you'll need an
application and so
an application for a new house or more
than one your house would be before
members either on weekly lists or
at a committee meeting so you you have
to control over those decisions
in any case um
[Music]
the final question i think that i've got
down is whether
there's another plausible vein with
access to the site and
i'm not aware of any other flexible
vehicle access
to the site um the accesses to the site
are those that are
on the plan submitted to this
application
have all your questions been answered
sorry could you clarify how many parking
spaces
are going to be made available in the
area
is
[Music]
for them to decide on any issues
uh around that area if they want to use
it down in gray's lane or
the ashland area am i correct
[Music]
um
and the additional question about about
15 000 pounds sorry
um maybe i didn't catch it quite what
officers are recommending
is that because our view taking
accountable
county council highways is that
that fifty thousand pounds of financial
contribution is all the customer
necessity tesla we are not
as officers recommending that that form
part of the heads of terms of the 106
agreement
if members were to um recognize the
deterministic application in our
recommendations
so if if members were mining to approve
and wanted that considered differently
and you're entitled to take a different
view um
but do you consider that that necessity
test was passed
then that money would we go to essex
county council highways authority
for them
obligations to be properly considered by
the committee
um
[Music]
that's it
is that possible
and then we um um to
decide who's has to answer that question
but certainly john bragg is here to
provide
further advice in relation to the
matters of which he has provided advice
right thank you so if if this
application was refused and if
the applicants were to go to appeal
in his considerable opinion i was going
to ask him many people that would
succeed
or fail
is
is
is to answer the particular points that
members
raised last november but also i was
asked
what my thoughts were with regard to the
merits of the people if there was a
refusal
um you have to consider
each of the points which was
individually and consider what the
evidence is
that's available we could support the
authority
in refusing planning permission on any
of those points
or you need exactly the same thing in
points that have been place during the
course of this evening
it's an evidential question um
members who have considerable experience
dealing with matters
have spoken and determined um
judicial has been referred to in
particular by one member
and the general approach which should be
taken
by
[Music]
very strongly um endorse what's been
said
[Music]
and i did it again in a video conference
session
was to look at the matter as though
i was put in the position of plain
inspection that's really what
i've been asked to do it in this
conference that's the way in which i've
approached the questions that i was
asked advising our
last vendor's meeting
doing the best i can
because one of course can never be
absolutely
sure of the outcome but doing
that i can i think that not only would
this
authority fail
in the future situation
[Music]
the planning officers
are bound
[Music]
[Music]
and from time to time uh the
relationship between the device
of the highway authority uh
in connection with what eventual
decision is taken by planning authority
has come before court
that's unsurprising
[Music]
occasions in particular
[Music]
[Music]
said that the most coaching reasons
would be required to act against
the decision of the decision against the
rights
of the public authority now what you
have had
what you've had here and is summarized
extremely well in the autopsy's report
page six four from paragraph
213 in the impact
and which of course
[Music]
in terms of the weight that you give to
what the higher authorities have to say
but this is not just being the process
of
law coming forward through its
consultants
consulting engineers
that's not what happened what
happened was that as is required of
course as a matter of policy it's there
in the end
we want to
its consultants came forward with a
transport assessment that wasn't
accepted initially
by essex essex went back and
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
engineers came
audit which then commented on by
um as designers
and then essex had the opportunity to
look at the highway surface
and the commentary that had been made on
it by department so there'd be a number
of different
layers of consideration behind the
material now the short point as far as
the viewer's community concern is
that that is a great deal of
technical work which has been undertaken
and although of course
about the impact of the development
and one fully understands concerns
the the harsh fact of the matter is that
there isn't
any hard evidence available to you
to challenge what has been put forward
by an argument on behalf of the globe as
scrutinized in detail it seems to me
that that puts the authority in a very
very weak
evidential position which is why i
say i think just taking the highway
aspect isn't it
that's why i think the authority is in a
very weak position
i hope that's helpful in illustrating
why
it is
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
gentlemen we've had a wide debate
and it does fall on someone to move this
discussion on
so i i feel too bound
based on what i said earlier to formally
move
the motion for approval as stated
in the report and seek someone to
uh
um
[Music]
not hear me
so we're going to forget about the 50
000 pound for the crossing on
praise lane which needs to be done this
i've been very tall
if this goes through okay
so that's the
um
uh foreign
[Music]
um
three people we need
so we
[Music]
together
fd
councillor reeves
counselor mrs gadsden
counselor norman
[Music]
councillor merrick
councillor newport
counselor mrs shaw okay
counselor sure
counselor smith
williams
when does this
yes
[Music]
um
as well
parliamentary
[Music]
of the actual arguments and
the basis is the definition of severe
is down to the district council to
determine
this district council is determining
that severe
severe level has been reached in traffic
in this area and therefore that is the
basis
for refusal
is
is
um you like to vote for
against yourself refusal
four council members
calculates
calcium
carcinoma
okay cancer williams
[Music]
thank you
thank you very much